Stars are just like us: nowhere near indestructible.
While shooting a TV show can be a relatively
cushy job, it can also sometimes be dangerous,
and potentially even fatal.
Here are some actors who were almost slain
due to stunts gone wrong, crew carelessness,
or their own near-fatal mistakes.
Matthew Fox
While filming a scene for the final episode
of Lost in 2010, star Matthew Fox nearly lost
his life, according to co-star Jorge Garcia,
who recounted the ordeal on his podcast about
the final season.
In the show's finale, Fox's Jack and Terry
O'Quinn's Locke fight on a cliff, and at one
point, Locke stabs Jack.
The show's creative team didn't think a collapsible
stunt knife looked convincing on camera, so
they filmed all the fighting with a real knife,
and planned to use the collapsible one only
to film the stabbing.
But they forgot to swap out the knives when
it came time to shoot the scene, and during
one take, O'Quinn accidentally started to
stab Fox with the real deal.
Fortunately, Fox took the stunt coordinator's
advice and wore protective kevlar under his
shirt, which likely saved his life.
Mariska Hargitay
Actress Mariska Hargitay prides herself on
doing her own stunts on NBC's long-running
police procedural Law and Order: SVU, and
for about 10 years, Hargitay did so without
incident, until October 2008, when she "fell
wrong" while trying to execute a stunt.
More accurately, she jumped, landed wrong,
and fell in such a way that she damaged a
lung, leading to a microscopic bleed.
Over the course of the next three months,
her lung slowly started collapsing, and she
eventually required multiple surgeries to
repair her lung and reverse the potentially
life-threatening condition.
Kristin Chenoweth
In the summer of 2012, actress Kristin Chenoweth
was filming scenes for what was supposed to
be a guest-starring arc on the CBS legal drama
The Good Wife.
But a freak accident ended those plans: a
piece of the lighting rig came loose and fell
right on her face, knocking her unconscious.
"I was just standing there with my prop phone,
and I just remember saying, 'Oh, this phone
is …' That's all I remember."
When she woke up later in the hospital, she
learned that she'd fractured her skull and
injured her hip and a rib.
Two years later, she was still in physical
therapy to recover from the accident.
Dominic Purcell
In early 2016, Dominic Purcell was filming
scenes in Morocco for the revival of Prison
Break.
In a bizarre turn of events, a piece of the
set broke free and fell right on top of the
actor's head.
"Blood was just pouring all over me, and then
my stunt guy came up to me, and he says, 'Well,
here's the thing: your head's cut open, I
can see your skull…"
Purcell suffered a broken nose and a minor
head injury.
But the show must go on: shooting continued
as Purcell was airlifted to a large hospital
in Casablanca.
Not long after the accident, Purcell reassured
fans on his Instagram page: "Pays to have
a thick skull when an iron bar falls on your
head!"
The Brady Bunch
In 1973, The Brady Bunch filmed at the King's
Island amusement park in Mason, Ohio.
In the episode, the plan was to have The Bradys
take a ride on the Red Racer roller coaster.
To get the shot, the producers wanted to put
a camera operator in the front car of the
coaster to catch the actors' real reactions.
Brady Bunch creator Sherwood Schwartz ordered
a test run of the coaster with just a camera
mounted on the front car — no camera operator,
and no Bradys.
The camera was too high and hit an overhang
during the test.
Were it the real deal, the camera operator
would have been struck as well, and the ride
could have been dangerous for him and the
Bradys.
Ultimately, the camera was rigged in a lower,
safer, spot, and the scene was filmed without
a hitch.
Aaron Paul
In the DVD commentary for the first season
of Breaking Bad, Aaron Paul revealed that
he was almost crushed while shooting a scene
in the desert in front of the show's RV-slash-mobile
meth lab. Paul adjusted his blocking while
filming with co-star Bryan Cranston, moving
a few steps away from where a massive rock
later fell from on top of the RV.
Turns out, there was a tarp on top of the
RV held in place by the rock, and the rock
was dislodged by a strong gust of wind.
As show creator Vince Gilligan notes, a 40-pound
rock falling 14 feet on top of Paul could
have ended his life if it wasn't for the last-minute
adjustment.
"Bam, I'm like, 'what the hell?'
y'know?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!